rescue teams in china are still
searching for possible survivors from a
crashed passenger jet so far no one has
been found alive the china eastern
airlines plane came down in the
mountains near wu zhu in the south of
the country on monday there were 123
passengers and nine crew on board
witnesses have described seeing the
plane fall in a near vertical descent
it is hoped that the flight recorders
will be found and provide key answers as
to why the plane crashed china has one
of the best airline safety records in
the world
rescuers scour the mountains of guanxi
for signs of life
the boeing 737 scattered across a remote
forest after falling from the sky
villagers nearby described the moment
the plane went down
[Music]
i heard a loud
people were doing their work peeling
tree bark
but they stopped everything
and rushed to see the crash
then the police arrived
shows the plane plunged 26 000 feet in
just three minutes
it's the country's first commercial air
crash since 2010.
china eastern airlines has grounded all
boeing 737-800 planes in its fleet
china's president expressed his shock an
immediate investigation has been ordered
we are deeply saddened by the accident
of the china eastern airlines passenger
flight
every effort to organize search and
rescue is being made
and we will find out the cause of the
accident as soon as possible to ensure
the absolute safety of aviation
operations
at guangzhou airport the plane's
destination families wait for news from
the mountainside
the flight data recorders could provide
clues as to what brought the plane down
but such investigations can take months
or even years